it's no secret that From Software's
games are heavily inspired Dark Souls
for example features many references to
Kintaro Meera's berserk blood-borne is
undeniably inspired by Lovecraft and you
know even slashy Souls is inspired by
money however among all of their titles
none of them are actually more inspired
or more present than secular which
actually takes place within a real
historical context and it's brimming
with references that will be understood
by a Japanese audience but might pass
over a Western one so sit back relax and
let us contextualize some of the most
fantastic stories within this game one
such story is that of the corrupted monk
the infested who guards the entrance to
the fountainhead palace while the game
describes her immortality as this the
fitting quality for an eternal watcher
of the palace we never really learned
how she became immortal that is until we
consider the folklore she is likely
inspired by the corrupted monks true
name is priestess Yao a likely reference
to the legend of yao bikuni so as the
tale goes a fisherman once caught this
unusual fish and he decided to invite
his friends around to sample its meat
however one of the guests peered into
the kitchen while the meal was being
prepared and he noticed that the fish
had a human face he warned the others
not to eat it and instead they wrapped
their portion of fish in paper and took
it home with them but one man who was
drunk on Saki he forgot to throw his
piece away and he gave it instead to his
daughter the next morning he freaked out
but the girl had appeared to suffer no
ill effects at all so he thought nothing
of it but over time she tragically began
to outlive everybody around her it turns
out the fish was an ino a sort of
mermaid and its flesh had imparted
immortality to the daughter who
eventually became known as yeah
bikuni the 800 year old buddhist priest
s this is a perfect example of how
folklore can deepen our understanding of
secular because the corrupted monk is
infested with centipedes and centipedes
other thing that imparts immortality in
secular so the implication is that
priestess y'all can trace her
immortality to the carp that's infested
with centipedes below Fountainhead lake
just like a bikuni traces her
immortality to the knee no the corrupted
monk is not the only warrior monk we see
in game and in fact we get to see and
fight a great deal of them at semper
temple upon mount Kongo while this area
is a part of a Sheena and the monks are
known to interact with our sheena on
occasion these people are sort of a more
separate group rather than trusty
vassals of the state indeed similar
warrior monk groups actually existed in
medieval and feudal Japan they merged
during the Heian period fuelled by
really fundamental disagreements on
Buddhist teachings between temples and
at first these warrior monk groups cared
for nothing but fighting one another yet
with the flow of time they began to
accumulate power as well
again pay war even saw commanders giving
presents to temples as an attempt to get
these warrior monks to fight on their
side and that however only lasted until
the end of the sangoku period where
Tokugawa Ieyasu and Oda Nobunaga saw
warrior monks as a threat to the
government so they were the first to
directly oppose them as a result of
Tokugawa's efforts warrior monks ceased
to exist by the time he became Shogun in
the 17th century
and speaking of Tokugawa and his
administration the interior ministry in
secular is likely the greatest threat
that the land of our China has ever seen
in the final act of the game we see the
ministry's warriors cutting through the
samurai of oshina as if there were
nothing exterminating pretty much
everybody who stands in their way and
yet while the words interior ministry is
thrown around a lot the question of
whose
stands behind the actions of the
interior ministry is never raised or
never answered however there are certain
hints that the in-game interior ministry
are warriors of real-life Tokugawa
Ieyasu which is evidenced by several
things first the emblems on their armor
they look really similar to the Tokugawa
family crest and the red troops the
ACA's Ornette was an elite group under
the command of one of Tokugawa's
generals in real life and as for the
ministry itself we should note that the
Japanese word knife foo does not
actually even mean interior ministry
instead it means interior minister which
was a government title in Japan Tokugawa
Ieyasu
was actually an interior minister during
the final years of the single GU era
thus we can conclude that the ash in a
clan might not be fighting an
organization but rather a man and that
man was most likely Tokugawa this in my
opinion is a bit of a missed opportunity
to have a concrete antagonist for the
forces of the Hashanah instead of just
the shadowy interior ministry now that
we've talked about fashion as enemies
let's move on to their great hero
Ian's title the sword Saint is not just
this fancy turn of phrase
it's actually an existing honorary title
that was given only to the best of
swordsmen one of such saints in real
life is Ito et Ossa kaga heesu who might
have even served as an inspiration for
eachine little is known of Ito except
that he was an outstandingly skilled
combatant proficient with both sword and
spear and skilled to such an extent that
many actually considered his powers
supernatural but here's the main thing
one of the fundamental principles of
Vito's techniques was moussaka which is
reacting to the enemy's attack not as
this conscious effort but instead
reacting spontaneously without thinking
moussaka is similar to machine a
technique that shares its name with the
Machine esoteric texts developed by
yishun himself in game
so these two are also similar in the
sense that both of them actually named
sword techniques after themselves ito
developed the ITO ryu which is the one
stroke school and asian developed a
combat arts called one mind a final
detail is that Ito's sword was also made
by sword makers from the ichimonji
school which obviously bears the same
name as this combat art in game another
legendary combatant in the world of
secular is Tom away she may not be
present during the events of the game
yet there's no doubt that she had a huge
influence on this world
Genichiro was her student and ischium
was her admirer and I think she was
undoubtedly inspired by Tom OE gozen a
legendary figure who is just as much of
an enigma as her in-game counterpart so
we don't know much about her we don't
know who her parents were we don't know
where and when she was born and some
scholars even doubt whether she existed
at all but the only thing true to all
records is that she was a certified
badass Tomo a goes on is described as an
accomplished Archer and a mounted
warrior a woman who was prepared to
confront both demons and gods a warrior
equal to a thousand men she served her
master loyally until he ordered her to
leave his side during his final battle
this was either done out of fear that
Thomas death would be more glorious than
his own or maybe because he wanted her
to spread word of his fate we don't know
much about what happened in this
legendary situation just as we don't
know much about what Tomo his life was
like after that Tom away was of the
akame and the center of worship for the
Okami was the Sakura dragon from the
West and the West is a really broad term
and while most people including me
speculate this to mean that the origins
are from China in the West there is also
evidence that the dragon could be of
Korean origin another place to the west
so the first fact supporting this is
that Eastern countries all had a
tendency to perceive dragons as
water-themed creatures and Koreans in
particular believed that dragons could
control rain fog lightning and thunder
another argument is that the sword of
the Dragon is carrying heavily resembles
the seven-branched sword which is
actually one of Japan's national
treasures according to the historical
documents and the inscription on the
blade this sword was a gift
Japan's ruler received from an ancient
Korean monarch geographically Korea is
also situated to the west of Japan so
Korea could be the home we return to to
return the dragon's blood in the end as
for the Dragons in Japanese mythology
there's a dragon god of rain in the
shinto pantheon that shares its name
with the okami clan alchemy no kami or
Kura okami a legendary deity of rain and
snow
however there actually exists another
version of this legend where this dragon
split into two different deities taka or
camino kami dragon god of mountaintops
and kura alchemy
no kami the dragon god of valleys so
these two in this alternate legend are
one in the same both of them together
presiding over rain and these two align
really well as you can guess with the
in-game divine dragon who presides over
mountaintops and the serpent God who
presides in the valleys in game this
dragon and the serpent are also linked
by their followers seeing as the sunken
valley clan are descendants of the okami
additionally this might also explain why
the serpents viscera is required to
create the cradle to escort the divine
dragon's heritage back to the west these
two creatures are linked and it kind of
makes sense that they might be two sides
of the same hole just like in the
Japanese legend it's worth noting that
snakes and Dragons in Japanese folklore
were mostly interchangeable with one
another in the sense that often one
version of a legend would have a dragon
in it and just as often the same legend
would feature a serpent
thus the connection between the divine
dragon and the serpent God may be deeper
than
appears to a western audience another
source of immortality in secular besides
the dragon's heritage our centipedes
that to have a certain place in Japanese
culture so what dragons were highly
revered centipedes on the other hand
were never popular among the Japanese
people they were seen as impure polluted
animals associated with death and even
regarded as yokai malevolent spirits and
while the game never presents us with a
direct confrontation between the divine
dragon and the centipedes there is a
Japanese folk tale called tewara toda
which features such a plot so a man
named Fujiwara was on a journey when he
noticed a giant serpent blocking his way
first he was startled but then he
eventually plucked up his courage and
walked on the serpents back until he
crossed to the other side the great
serpent impressed by the man's courage
then reappeared before the man in his
true form that of a dragon king he
requested the man's aid with killing his
enemy the centipede living on mount
Mikami and Fujiwara agreed battling the
monster however proved difficult the
hero shot one arrow then another and yet
neither arrow hurts the Beast even a
little bit
he then remembered one of the centipedes
greatest weaknesses humans saliva
Fujiwara spat on his arrow shot it right
onto the beasts eye and it fell dead
it's a great missed opportunity that no
similar mechanic made it into the game a
common host for the centipedes in-game
are the infested monks that we see in
semo temple whose infestation has become
a symbol of worship these monks design
was almost definitely inspired by the
real-life Buddhist monks who actually
underwent a process called sokushinbutsu
a process of self-mummification in which
they would actually mummify their own
bodies while they were still alive in
order to succeed in this amoung should
first follow a really strict diet they
eliminated all of the fat in their
bodies and then he had to also stop
consuming any type of liquid so that his
organs would shrink and he would begin
to mummify the monks would die reciting
a mantra over and over again
perpetuating themselves in a meditating
pose this practice was popular in a
Mountain dwelling version of Buddhism
called shugendo and in fact there is a
checkpoint named shugendo in the
mountainous parts of semper temple the
last secret for today will be about one
of the first npcs we meet in-game the
sculptor as we learned from
conversations with Emma
his old nickname from his shinobi times
was Ranga tang hanbei one of the
sculptors friends actually calls him
sekito which is a play on the Japanese
word for orangutan which is shoujo a
shoujo is synonymous with being a heavy
drinker a meaning that originated in a
play in the play shoujo are presented as
this race of intelligent spirits with
long shaggy red hair and an extreme
fondness for sake this video was written
with the help of Zhu rail who you can
learn more about in the description she
told me and so many of us about Japanese
culture and history so if you're
interested you can actually go read more
of her posts over on reddit but thank
you for watching and I'll see you next
time